Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So Leute, auf geht's.
Ähm, ich weiß nicht, wie ich drauf gekommen bin.
Ich kann es auch nicht so genau sagen.
Ich hab' heute Morgen mir mal Gedanken gemacht, so nach dem Motto, was für Spiele so in den letzten paar Jahren mir gefallen haben.
Und natürlich sind wir so auf die üblichen Sachen gekommen, so wie Witcher 3 und Black Mesa, was wir schon gespielt haben.
Und irgendwie hab' ich mir gedacht, also, sagen wir mal, die Titanfall Kampagne war doch echt nice.
Und das Game, ich mein, das Game kam raus, ähm, Release Date 2016 oder so?
Also das kam raus vor ungefähr viereinhalb Jahren.
Ich hab's direkt nach Release gespielt, ich hab' keine Ahnung mehr.
Ich hab' keine Ahnung mehr, was genau passiert.
Ähm, deswegen hab' ich mir gedacht, wir können das Ganze mal on stream spielen.
Und mal gucken, wie weit wir kommen.
Ich weiß noch, dass das Spiel nicht sonderlich lang ist.
Das Spiel ist, weiß ich, fünf Stunden lang, sechs Stunden lang.
Also, entweder schaffen wir's heute oder aber wir schaffen's morgen.
Ich glaube, das hatte zwölf Kapitel in der Main Quest.
Also Main Quest, ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Die Hauptkampagne, ich glaub, zwölf Kapitel oder irgendwie sowas.
Und es war nicht sonderlich lang, es war relativ easy.
So, ähm, ja, was gibt's noch zu sagen?
Wir müssen wieder, wir müssen Essenspause machen, so irgendwann 18 Uhr.
Da gucken wir uns wieder, oder 18, 19 Uhr irgendwie.
Da gucken wir uns dann wieder eine Runde YouTube-Essen-Video an.
Und ich futter schnell, was?
Datenzentrale Frankfurt, zwei Adresse leaked.
Oh fuck, Alter. Sekunde.
Leute, das kann nicht sein, dass ich das leake, leake.
So, jetzt.
Das war aber close, close call, Alter. Ganz, ganz knapp.
Kennst du Mei Waifu ist für Twitch von Triax?
Nee, kenn ich nicht.
Ich, ich, ich kenn bloß Q-Chat.
Übrigens, das ist ein Source-Game, wenn ich das richtige Erinnerung hab.
Das dürfte eines der letzten neun Spiele sein auf der Source-Engine.
Irgendwie hab ich eine Hand zu Source-Engine-Games, ne?
Das dürfte eines der zuletzt erschienen Spiele überhaupt auf der Source-Engine sein.
Weiß nicht, was noch danach rausgekommen ist.
Black Mesa hab ich nicht on stream fertig gespielt. Wir haben bis ins letzte Level gespielt.
Und ich sag euch ganz ehrlich, ich hab's off stream, ich hab's off stream durchgespielt.
Das letzte Level ist wirklich schlecht.
Das letzte Level suckt. Also nicht Titanfall, sondern Black Mesa.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch damit quälen soll.
Es ist rot, grüne, dunkle Alien-Schalter-Rätsel-Stells und Fließband-Stells.
Also das ist nicht so spannend.
Der Boss-Fight ist gut von Black Mesa, aber das letzte Level, das zieht sich.
Also wir haben bestimmt noch drei Stunden vor uns, Black Mesa.
Und warum steht hier Titanfall gar nicht drin?
Warum steht hier Titanfall gar nicht drin?
Ach so, Games. Das dürfte eines der letzten Spiele sein.
WTF? Ich weiß, dass Titanfall ein Source-Game ist, garantiert.
Das ist definitiv ein Source-Game.
Ranker.com, das klingt schon nach Scamars, Alter.
Titanfall ist ein Source-Game, 100%. Ich weiß es genau.
Ja, sage ich doch. Steht sogar bei Wikipedia.
Und wenn das Wikipedia sagt, dann stimmt es. Wikipedia lügt nicht.
Ja, da, sage ich doch. Die anderen Wikipedia-Seiten sind bloß zu lahm.
Apex. Ja, Apex ist ja im Endeffekt Titanfall.
Ja, ich weiß, es ist nicht wirklich Titanfall, aber es ist schon ganz klar zu erkennen, dass da Titanfall drunter ist.
Also Apex und Titanfall ist, also was ich da vom Movement gesehen habe alles, das ist eindeutig Titanfall genommen und in Battle Royale Games rausgebaut.
Ja, Flag ist genau, deswegen habe ich keinen Bock, das nochmal zu spielen.
Ich habe es Offstream durchgespielt, Black Mesa.
Und das letzte Level sackt, wirklich. Ich habe keinen Bock, das nochmal zu spielen.
Das sackt Hardcore.
Der Rest ist so nice, die haben es voll versaut mit dem Kack-Level am Ende.
So viel kann man aus einem alten Engine machen, warum sieht dann CSGO nicht besser aus?
Also CS sieht erstens ganz gut aus. Muss man sagen, ich meine es gibt deutlich schlechtere Endgames.
Und außerdem das wichtige an CS ist, dass CS sich wie CS anfühlt und CS halt absolut auf Performance getrimmt ist.
Was meinst du, warum CS auf jedem Gammelrechner läuft?
Ich meine, wir haben uns letztens auf YouTube doch ein Video angeguckt, wo einer irgendwie so einen China-Wish-Rechner oder so zusammengebaut hat mit Skamars-Grafikkarte und so.
Und sogar auf diesem Kack-Rechner, auf diesem wirklich absolut untere Bodensatz-Rechner ist CSGO irgendwie mit 45 FPS gelaufen.
Und CS, also wenn man es heute schafft, ohne Spaß, wie der Asiton jetzt gesagt hat, wirklich, wenn man es heute schafft, besser gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man es schaffen sollte,
sich einen Rechner heute zu bauen, wo nicht CSGO ordentlich drauf läuft.
Das geht nicht. Das ist nicht möglich.
Würde CS für ARM erscheinen, würde es auf einem Raspberry Pi laufen mit 5 FPS.
Sogar da würde es wahrscheinlich laufen, komplett in Software gerendert oder so.
Ich weiß gar nicht, hat Source Engine überhaupt einen Software-Renderer?
Ne, oder sowas haben die wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich wäre ja auch total beknackt, heutzutage brauchst du sowas nicht.
Heutzutage hast du auf jeden Fall irgendwas, was ein bisschen 3D kann.
Hat Source einen Software-Renderer?
Ich meine, man könnte eine Software OpenGL implementieren, wobei ich weiß gar nicht, ob Source...
Kann Source OpenGL?
Ach, kein Schimmer. Ist auch egal.
Wir fangen jetzt an.
Also Zeitplan ist ungefähr so.
Wir fangen jetzt an und dann hören wir auf.
Was sagt ihr dazu?
Denn das ist Next Level Zeitplan.
Yes, excellent.
Exquisite, exquisite.
Okay, ne, also wir fangen jetzt an.
Und dann in einer Stunde esse ich was und wir gucken uns ein paar, gucken uns ein Essen wieder.
Dann spielen wir weiter.
Spätestens 22.30 Uhr ist Schluss, weil ich muss morgen wieder arbeiten gehen.
Und nächste Woche, Leute, nächste Woche kommt ein neuer Azubi zu uns.
Der ist eigentlich schon heute gekommen, aber ich mein, ich geh nicht auf die Arbeit.
Einfach nur so.
Ich bin ja montags nie da und...
Aber morgen, morgen kommt ein neuer Azubi.
Das heißt, ich muss zumindest ein bisschen, ein bisschen wach sein, dass ich dem was erzählen kann.
Montags arbeiten in 2020, Alter.
Macht er den Fritzbox-Test? Vielleicht.
Vielleicht darf er den Fritzbox-Test morgen schon machen.
Aber wahrscheinlich werde ich ihm morgen erst mal erklären, dass er sich eine Linux-VM installieren soll.
Linux auf seinem Notebook wird er wahrscheinlich nicht machen dürfen, weil er braucht für die anderen Abteilungen,
worin er auch hingeht, wahrscheinlich die Standard-Windows-Installation auf seinem Rechner.
Also wahrscheinlich werde ich ihm sagen, der soll sich eine Linux-VM machen.
Da ist er erst mal einen Tag mit beschäftigt.
Ob er da einen Kanal kennt?
Ich denke nicht.
Wer kennt meinen Kanal heute schon?
Ein Azubi kannte den.
Ein Azubi kannte den, mein Channel.
Aber der ist Anwendungsentwickler, der ist nicht bei uns.
Die waren mal einen Tag bei mir.
Mal einen halben Tag bei mir und da hat er gesagt, ja, du heißt Maxus, ja.
Ja, irgendwie kommt mir deine Stimme bekannt vor.
Aber er sagt nichts, aber er sagt nichts.
Er sagt, ah, guck mal, hier, First Revealed, Alter.
Wobei, Zweiter, Zweiter, Zweiter war, Last, Zweiter.
Eule Number One.
Was ich beruflich mache, das ist ganz einfach.
Da habe ich eben ein komplettes Video drüber gemacht, wo ich das ausführlich erkläre.
Das da, guck mal.
Hallo, Jungs.
Das da, das mache ich auf der A...
Was ist denn das?
What the fuck?
Geht das schon immer auf YouTube?
Was ist das?
Das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Das ist Mobile.
Das ist Mobile Crap.
Mobile Crap, geh von meinem Desktop runter.
What?
Mobile Crap.
Ich will, ich will den Mobile Müll sicher haben auf meinem Desktop.
Geh weg.
Weiche, Alter, wo haben wir es hier?
Mobile.
Was kommt als nächstes?
YouTube als Elektron-Anwendung.
Also, wenn es sich interessiert, kannst du dir das hier angucken.
Bei mir auf YouTube.
Das mache ich auf der Arbeit, als der VORPSE-Engineer.
Da erkläre ich 14 Minuten lang, was ich auf der Arbeit mache.
So, und eine Frage beantworte ich jetzt noch, bevor es losgeht.
Übrigens, bevor ich die Frage beantworte, also Überleitung,
ich habe das Game auf Deutsch installiert, weil ich nicht aufgepasst habe.
Und falls die deutsche Sprachausgabe zu nervig ist,
dann müssen wir die umstellen nachher, weil wir erstens Pause machen.
Fritzbox-Test, ja.
Wer weiß, vielleicht guckt ja einer zu.
Also der Fritzbox-Test mit Azubis ist, wir haben das Passwort vergessen
und er soll die Fritzbox resetten, ohne dass er auf das Web-Interface kommt.
Es gibt verschiedene Varianten, wie man das machen kann.
Achso, und natürlich ein neues WLAN-Passwort vergeben, also nichts.
Wir haben normalerweise auf der Arbeit keine Fritzbox,
aber wir haben halt da eine stehen, genau für unter anderem solche Dinger.
Die haben auch eine Reset-Möglichkeit, ja.
Haben sie auch, genau.
Ich wollte dich jetzt noch für eine Frage beantworten.
Ich habe schon wieder voll verpeilt.
Ich wollte doch irgendwann eine Frage beantworten.
Ich habe gesagt, bevor ich diese Frage beantworte,
und dann habe ich vergessen, was ich beantworten wollte.
Man kommt eigentlich das Server-Video, der Sound ist ein bisschen im Arsch.
Ich muss gucken, dass ich den Sound irgendwie so kriege,
dass es nicht zu nervig ist.
Wenn die deutsche Sprache scheiße ist,
dann stellen wir ihn erstens in der Essenspause um.
Einfach um die Azumi zu testen, genau.
Der Typ kann auch ruhig auf YouTube suchen.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich sage, du darfst nicht.
Du kannst alles machen. Hauptsache, du schaffst es zu resetten.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich beantworten wollte für eine Frage.
Irgendetwas war doch noch offen.
Beruflich haben wir schon...
Hm...
Ja, leider.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen die Musik aus und legen los.
Falls die deutsche Sprachausgabe zu nervig ist,
können wir das Ganze immer noch umschalten.
Aber wir gucken uns das Ganze mal an.
Auf geht's.
Und wie immer am Anfang,
weil Windows und Audio-Settings, ihr kennt das Spiel ja,
Windows und Audio-Settings sind ja immer so eine Sache für sich.
Die verstellen sich ja öfters mal.
Müsst ihr mir sagen, wie die Lautstärke ist,
ob ich sie noch lauter oder leiser machen muss.
Guck mal ganz kurz.
Also, Kampagne neu.
Huge Intro-Sequenz.
Ich glaube, das Intro habe ich das erste Mal auch nicht geguckt.
Durch all meine Schlachten im Grenzland habe ich eines gelernt.
Der Pilot ist das Alpha-Tier.
Oh ja.
Guckt bestimmt KLS.
Elegant und doch tödlich.
Schafsinnig.
Listig.
Und unaufhaltsam.
Weil sozusagen der Pilot ist.
Ein Pilot sieht die Welt mit anderen Augen.
Bloße Wände werden zu alternativen Wegen.
Piloten kämpfen anders.
Durch ihre Erfahrung mit Täuschungsmanövern gelingt es ihnen,
allen Widerigkeiten zu trotzen.
Warum wirft er die Waffe weg?
Weil er im Schlachtfeld abhebt, ist die Verbindung mit seinem Titan.
Zusammen mit seinem Titan kann er nur von einer Übermacht bezwungen werden.
Oder von seinesgleichen.
Das Grenzland war seit jeher meine Heimat.
Seit Jahren wird es schon von der IMC zerstört.
Sie beuten Ressourcen aus.
Verschmutzen und zerstören unseren Planeten.
Und schlagen jeden Widerstand gewaltsam nieder.
Trotz der jüngsten Erfolge auf Demeter sind wir noch weit davon entfernt,
die IMC endgültig zu besiegen.
Noch bin ich ein Schütze der Miliz, die für die Befreiung des Grenzlandes kämpft.
Und weit davon entfernt ein Pilot zu werden.
Wenn dieser Tag kommt,
hoffe ich, mich als würdig zu erweisen.
Die Titan sind teuer.
Wäre das eine Ausrede? Die haben EA als Publisher.
Die haben genug Geld.
Oh, drücke Spaces. Geht weiter.
Ah, yes.
Tutorial-Mission.
Das Schiff hat die Simulationskapsel zurückgesetzt. Wir müssen sie neu kalibrieren.
Oh, ich muss in den Graphics-Settings. Sekunde, Sekunde. Graphics-Settings.
Graphics, Graphics, Graphics.
Also. Moment. Filmkörnung weg.
Ich mein, the fuck, Filmkörnung. Habt ihr es gesehen, wie das flimmert?
Also erstmal Filmkörnung weg.
Äh, flüssiger Sprint.
Meinetwegen.
Ähm.
Dreifach gebannt.
Vsync, Leute.
Was, was, was sind wir hier?
Vsync.
Ich glaub, es geht los.
Was hältst du von 21 zu 9 Monitoren?
Was soll ich von 21, die sind groß.
Hab ich auf der Arbeit auch einen. Find ich gut.
Für, für mir daheim hab ich lieber 2, äh, 2, 16 zu 9.
Aber kann man machen.
Vsync aus. Textures.
Streaming-Budget Wahnsinn.
Excellent Wahnsinn. Rest sehr hoch. Alles gut. Flüssiger Sprint. Filmkörnung.
Foff, Foff. Müssen wir mal gucken, wie es ist in-Game. Vielleicht machen wir ein bisschen hoch.
Okay. Übernehmen. Zack. Drück.
Äh, Steuerung gucken wir gleich.
Bisschen leise, oder?
Ach nee, doch. Geht.
Äh, Steuerung ist perfekt.
Ja, Lautstärke ist gut, ne?
Aber endlich.
Um neue Fähigkeiten zu lernen, müssen wir geistig fit sein.
Ah, viel besser.
Eigentlich bin ich gar nicht für Ihre Ausbildung verantwortlich, aber Sie haben Potenzial.
Außerdem können wir den Krieg. Wir hatten schon Zeit für Hierarchien, oder?
Legen wir einen Zahn zu. Aktiviere Jump-Kit-Unterstützung.
Wenn ich bei eins gemerkt habe, ist das Wand-Rennen-Movement besser als in allen anderen Games.
Da kann Black Ops einpacken. Und es ist halt eindeutig, dass das von Apex, ne?
Beziehungsweise, nein, Schwachsinn. Das in Apex ist das von Titanfall.
Oh, warte mal. Iiih. Autosprint. Autosprint.
Äh, Autosprint. Immer Autosprint. Alle Autosprint.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Titans irgendwie Rennenergie hatten, wo man aufpassen muss.
Okay. Kann sein, dass wir auch die ein oder anderen Sachen...
Ah, so ist besser. Die ein oder anderen Sachen ändern müssen.
In Apex kann man nicht... Was in Apex kann... Wat?
Man kann aber doch in Apex so komisch schleiden.
Ach, nee. In Apex, das ist dieser komische...
Das ist dieser komische Roboter mit dem Seil, der sich da rumschwingen kann, ne?
Du kannst... Stimmt. Jaja, klar. Du kannst gar nicht anwenden.
Ja, Wohnschleider, das kann man hier auch machen.
Ich sehe schon gleich... Moment. Steuerung.
Da. Wir wollen nämlich das da.
Boost. Ich will hier keinen Boost aktivieren. Ich will das da auf C.
Okay. Und ich will Zielen. Zielen. Wie ist Ziel? Ein Aus. Zielen will ich auf rechte Maustaste haben.
Sodass man es gedrückt halten muss. Übernehmen.
Ich glaube, jetzt passt alles.
Das ist sehr gut.
Na, komm. Das schaffen wir auch so.
Man ist doch schneller, wenn man... Ja, genau.
Aber man kann hier oben nicht rausspringen. Das wäre natürlich auch fies, vor allem.
Direkt erst mal aus der Map-Jump.
Genau. Ja. Das Movement haben sie richtig gut gemacht.
Du kannst... Das ist ein bisschen... Also, ich muss euch ja sagen...
Ich glaube, das Lucio-Movement in Overwatch war von Titanfall inspiriert.
Das hat sehr viele Parallelen. Zum Beispiel, dass du nur einmalig pro Wand rennen kannst.
Also, das hat schon... Und du klebst auch ähnlich an der Wand.
Das ist schon ähnlich. Guck, jetzt musst du erst wieder abspringen, dass du an der Wand rennen kannst.
Also, ist schon ähnlich.
Was haben wir denn hier? Big Brain Scope-Waffe und Low Brain-Pistole.
Waffe laden.
Da war einfach nicht drauf gekommen.
Eats. X. Ah nee, ich muss... Okay, ich muss.
Pock. Richtig Pock.
Haben wir das gemacht.
Huge Aim.
Okay, den Parkour werde ich jetzt richtig verkacken.
Kann man hier eigentlich... Konnte man umstellen, wie die Waffen schießen? Auto und Burst und so?
Nee, ich glaube, das ging Titanfall nicht.
Du hast runtergefallen.
Huge Move.
Das Move macht Ultra-Boarding im Game. So, pass auf, Big Brain Move.
Und, was kriegen wir von Schwierigkeitsgrad auf Schwier? Das heißt, wir waren richtig pro.
Jawoll.
Nochmal.
Parkour unter 30 Sekunden. Da gibt es bestimmt Speedruns zu, hä? Da gibt es 100% Speedruns zu. Wir gucken in der Essenspause...
Speedrun. World Record. Wir gucken uns in der Pause den Speedrun an. Da gibt es 100%.
Nee, so funktioniert das schon mal nicht, wie ich mir das gedacht habe.
Ey, der Typ ist schneller als ich. Was ist da los? Der killt aber nichts, der Noob.
Der killt nichts, der ist übelst. Der scammed. Okay, so funktioniert das schon mal nicht. Meine erste Route war besser.
Okay, okay. Nicht schlecht. Sind Sie fertig?
Ich bin bereit für den nächsten Schritt. Ich würde gerne noch ein wenig... Jaja, ich bin bereit.
Ich bin bereit für den nächsten Schritt.
Wo kommt eigentlich das Wasser her? Das ist irgendwie ein bisschen... Physics.
Was? Titan? Ich dachte, das dürfen nur Piloten.
Wave. Du musst Bunny hoppen, das geht in dem Game nicht, oder?
V. Oh, what? Wrong guys.
Die Kacke ist am Dampfen. Na dann.
Titan fall, genau. Was? 12 Sekunden ist der Burn?
Da sterben wir sogar darauf. Who cares?
Krasser Betonung, Glück. Das kommt aber raus, wenn du den Boys extra kein Skript irgendwie gibst.
Wo drin steht so, was gerade passiert? Heute gehen wir auf einen neuen Planeten. Vielleicht sterben wir darauf.
Egal. Jolo. Schwierig, Leute. Ja, oder? Wir spielen auf Speer. Nein, Speer. Nein, Meister. Wir machen was schwierig.
Ich hab das Game drei, vier Jahre nicht mehr gespielt. Ich will erst mal auf den Meister stellen.
Ich frag mich gerade, wie man diesen Parcours in 11 Sekunden machen soll. 11 Sekunden, da musst du dich bestimmt durch die Wand klitschen oder so.
Wir gucken uns das gleich an. Intro. Ich bin mal ruhig. Letztes Mal wurde ich angeschissen, da ich nicht so viel Zwischensequenzen reinlabern darf.
Hier. Psst. ASMR-Stream. Reitenfall 2.
Ich sehe haufenweise Robitalabwehrsysteme.
Erinnert mich an Halo oder S.T.
Stabilisieren. Langzupentanyl verabgreifen. Temporäre Nebenwirkungen mit Höchstmöglichen koordiniert.
Ich kann nichts mehr.
Das ist ja gut. Wir können noch gar nicht sliden, fällt mir gerade auf. Wir können noch gar nicht sliden, weil wir sind ja noch gar kein Pilot.
Ich wollte gerade reinsliden und es war keine so gute Idee. Wir sind noch movemovemovemovemovemovemovemovemovemove.
Wir haben auch nur, ah nee, Moment. Das ist ja Destiny. Das ist so eine typische Destiny-Waffe.
Oh, das ist meiner.
Ich bin dann geschreckt.
Apex. Apex mehr als ich.
Was ist das? Budget Wars.
Apex.
Jetzt kommt noch mal Tutorial Mission. Also eine halbe Tutorial Mission.
First try.
Oh, ich darf mich ultra schnell bewegen gerade.
So, Game vorbei. Abspann. Titan ist tot. Oh nee, doch nicht.
Foff. Ja, Foff können wir wirklich umstellen. Tap. Okay, hm, wo könnte ich hinmüssen? Ja, ich muss, ich muss. Ach, da muss ich hinmüssen.
Nein, ohne Tap wäre das nicht möglich gewesen. Wir können gleich Foff umstellen. Ich wollte erst mal gucken, wie es in Game ist.
Jetzt wird's ernst. Jetzt wird's ernst. Pass auf ihn auf. Deutsches Voice Acting Supreme.
Seirox Ino, Stufe eins. Fünf Monate lang, danke schön. Tap.
So, ich denke, Lautstärke ist standardmäßig ziemlich gut gewesen, ne? Wir können erst auf Englisch stellen, da muss ich neu downloaden. Erst so in einer halben Stunde. Aber wir machen dann mal eine Abstimmung, weil es könnte durchaus sein, dass die meisten sogar auf Deutsch gucken wollen.
Ich werde es in der Sprache spielen, was die meisten gucken wollen. Mir ist das ziemlich wurscht. So, der Hazard Suite muss ich erst mal hier initialisieren.
Was haben wir denn da? Eine Pistole? Achso, Waffe und nochmal Waffe. Easy. Ah, Batterien sammeln. Exzellenter Wahl. Bitte stell auf Spanisch. Ich stell, ich stell nicht auf Spanisch. Ich stell auf, ähm, ich stell auf Koreanisch oder so.
Wow, das war aber ein unfaires Movement.
Nein. Ach, guck mal da. Ich bin eigentlich, ne, die Waffe sackt, diese komische Destiny Waffe, die sackt, aber lieber die hier. Ich sehe in diesem Spiel den Waffen nicht an, was es für Waffen sind. Sieht aus wie eine Assault Rifle. Und das sieht aus wie eine SMG. Ich hoffe, das stimmt.
Flatline.
Erstmal ne Runde Jump Swarm.
Die halten mehr aus, als ich gedacht habe. Noch was, was mich echt an Halo erinnert. Musste man in Halo nicht auch in Halo 3? Musste man nicht, was war das für ein Game? Doch in Halo hat man doch auch Helme gesammelt.
Oder? Ne, ne, ne, der hat mal Totenköpfe gesammelt in Halo 3. Oder? Totenköpfe, nicht Helme, genau. Schädel. Totenköpfe, Alter. Sind wir im Kindergarten. Das ist kein schöner Totenkopf.
Ja, man muss sich hier halt anpassen.
Ist klar. Natürlich. Das ist selbstverständlich genau das, was man jetzt machen würde. Erstmal ergeben. Komm wir ergeben uns jetzt. Wir testen jetzt, ob man sich ergeben kann. Ich heule nämlich Gegner. Ich ergebe mich.
Ich ergebe mich. Ich ergebe mich. Geht nicht.
Gebatet. Um nicht zu sagen, es ist gar nicht. Wo müssen? Ah, da. Da müssen wir hin. Wie, das hat er überlegt? Das war so was von dem Kopf. Ich nehme mal mein Assault schon mal. Ich hatte doch eben noch.
Das hat doch hier so eine.
Stellst du uns mal an der Seite lang? Jawoll, da fliegen die Köpfe.
Was ist mit dem los? Hat er sich irgendwie.
Hab ich überhaupt nicht gesehen.
Oh, da kommen sie rüber geschwenkt.
Also ich meine. Als Pilot ist man auch ganz schöner Noob Gordon Freeman hätte das hier alleine mit dem Brecheisen gemacht.
Was haben wir hier zu bieten? DRM. Oh, das klingt nach Schneiber.
Schneiber.
Wo ist er? Oder wo sind sie?
Was?
Sehr fair. Sehr fair. Alles klar.
Okay. Nehmen wir noch mal. DRM. Schneiber. Jetzt weiß ich ja wo sie sind. Sie sind unter mir.
Da. Meinst du ich hätte den Dude gesehen?
Okay, jetzt aber Schneiber.
So wie sich das gehört.
Also eins muss man sagen, ich bin ja immer wieder beeindruckt.
Ich wollte mir die Umgebung angucken. Was die Leute immer noch so aus einer Source Engine rausholen.
Das ist jetzt eine neuere Variante. Das wird jetzt nicht auf dem Stand von Half Life 2 Release oder so sein.
Aber es sieht doch trotzdem nice aus. Ich meine, darf man hier runter oder stirbt mich wohl jetzt einfach mal aus, ob man sich das angucken darf?
Ich meine, es sieht doch echt ganz hübsch aus. Es ist halt ein bisschen kantig. Ja, okay.
Ich meine, es ist auch ein Game, was viereinhalb Jahre alt ist und auf der Endung basiert.
Von einem Game von 2006 oder so. Aber trotzdem, wenn man sich Mühe gibt, auch wenn es halt ziemlich hardcoded Schatten sind,
aber wenn man sich Mühe gibt, sieht das trotzdem nice aus.
Oh, das hält gut was aus. Das können wir bestimmt wegschneiden.
Oh, Achtung Schleiber.
Was ist hier los?
What? Von wo? Die Gegner, die mich killen in dem Game, die sehe ich alle nicht.
Wo soll denn hier bitte schon ein Gegner gewesen sein gerade? Ich war so nice gestälzt.
Ach da. Hat mich das Viech eben gewäscht. Kann das sein?
Okay, jetzt kommt nichts mehr raus. Muss ich erstmal hier triggern.
Oh, die zappeln mir ein bisschen viel. Das ist schwer. Da ist man relativ schnell tot.
Okay, wir machen das jetzt so, wir schneiden jetzt das fetteste Viech, weil das fetteste Viech sieht so aus,
aber das Sound ist gerade die anderen Dudes. Genau, und jetzt nur noch der da. Easy Win. Ah, der hat es überlebt.
Aber nicht mehr lange.
Das waren auch keine Soldaten, das waren irgendwie die Roboter. Kriegt der CPU überhitzt oder irgendwie sowas.
Ah, da rüber. Peter muss man bei Roboter nicht callen. Und bei Alien-Kirchen zählt Peter auch nicht.
Wow, knapp.
Ich wollte mich schon ergeben, ihr wolltet mich ergeben.
Das wird Peter anders sehen. Ja, ich glaube mit Peter kann man über sowas auch nicht diskutieren.
Was schießt die Propagandathrone ab? Gibt eine Achievement? Welche Propagandathrone?
Da müssen wir bestimmt durch.
Nee, da müssen wir nicht durch. Da passen wir nicht durch. Wir sind zu Kokona.
Das brauchen wir. Jetzt müssen wir unseren Typen wieder verwenden können. Ach, der lebt noch, der Captain.
Nee, oder? Kann nicht sein. Spätestens jetzt wäre der von diesen komischen Dingern aufgefressen.
Apex Light. Meinst du die Thron?
Ja, da sind wir wieder.
Big Brain-Rolle. Huge Brain-Ausweich-Vanöver. Oh, da kommt eine Granate. Ich könnte weglaufen. Nein, ich rolle mich.
Ja, wer bist du?
Na gut.
Ah, noch eine Batterie. Ich dachte, ich kann jetzt Titan Bash machen. Oh, da muss ich hin. Wie komme ich da lang?
Jetzt BT stelle ich mich nicht so an. Das ist eine dreiviertelvolle Batterie. Ist das ein Samsung Akku oder so? Was ist da los?
Die Throne? War das die Throne? Äh, was? Oh, jetzt habe ich nicht zugehört. Wir sind nett zu unserem Teil.
Ich jutsche. Ich jutsche-Movement. Ich muss hier lang? Hier rüber, oder? Ich muss doch hier langschleiden?
Ja. Nice Slider. Moment, Moment. Hier kann ich gar nicht sliden. Kann ich hier sliden oder was?
Nee, kann ich gar nicht sliden. Aber hier kann man bestimmt einfach so drüberspringen. Erstmal Anlauf nehmen. Aber hier kann man schleiden.
Ich muss mir jetzt noch ein bisschen an das Movement wieder gewöhnen. Jetzt muss man bestimmt von Wand zu Wand-Stells machen.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung. Was war das? Knapp. Denkst du wir überleben das hier?
Wir haben keine Option. Wir müssen improvisieren, wenn wir überleben wollen.
Äh, äh, äh. What? Moment. Ah, Doppelsprung auf Saving.
Der wird jetzt gestälzt.
Blatsch. Was haben wir denn hier so zu bieten? DRM haben wir schon. Elektrogranate.
Ich glaube man kann keine Granatensplitter. Man rüstet so einen Granaten-Mod einfach aus.
Ohje, die kann man schneiden von hier oben. Bam. Kopf weg. Next.
Oder war das eine Stells-Mission? Was hält denn das Ding aus?
Ey, was hält denn das da hinten aus? WTF? Ah, jetzt ist es kaputt. Normal wie immer.
Loot gibt es nicht in dem eigentlichen Sinne. Es gibt irgendwelche Loot-Kisten, da ist ja nichts drin.
Man kann mit jeder Waffe wahrscheinlich alles killen. Was ist das? Eine Shotgun?
Can it run Crysis? Ja guck mal, wir haben sogar einen Stells-Mode. Moment, wer hat noch hier eine Shotgun? Ja, das ist doch immer eine Shotgun.
Oh, die sind so schnell gestorben. Ich hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass raussteckt keine Granate mehr.
Es ist cool wie die Helme wegfliegen. Das fühlt sich richtig gut an das Ballern in dem Game.
Reload. Das ist doch die Speedrun-Shotty. Weiß jemand, wie lange der Worldre... Warte, ganz kurz, das muss ich mal nachgucken.
Speedrun, Titanfall 2. Was ist denn der Rekord? Eine Stunde und 19? Alter, das müssen wir uns angucken.
Nicht jetzt, aber dann. Das gucken wir uns an. Wir gucken uns mal den Titanfall-Speedrun an.
B.T., wem gehört diese Stimme? Nein, nein, wir sind hier einfügsam.
Ach, man kann einfach beides fragen. Das Movement macht so viel Bock in dem Game.
Das Movement ist so richtig nice gemacht. Warum haben sie eigentlich Wallrun in Apex nicht eingebaut?
Gut, wahrscheinlich hätten sie Probleme gehabt mit den Maps. Aber warum? Ich meine, du kannst in Apex auch sauschnell überall drauf.
Weil du in Apex kein Pilot bist. Was ist denn das für eine Begründung? Ich meine, wenn sie ein Spiel entwickeln, die hätten nicht ohne Probleme auch Pilot machen können.
Oder irgendwie was anderes, was Wallrun kann. Das muss irgendwelche Gameplay-Entscheidungen gewesen sein, warum man gesagt hat, man möchte...
Guck mal, da oben, was ist denn das? Einen Helm, noch einen Helm. Wie kommt man denn da drauf?
Da muss man bestimmt hier Stellens machen, hier irgendwie Anlauf nehmen. Wartet mal, da muss man bestimmt Anlauf nehmen, runter, slide und dann irgendwie...
Ja! Huge Brain-Movement.
Das Movement macht so Bock.
Oh, da kommt was. VT, kannst du was machen? VT ist ab.
Jawoll, es wird Titan-Bash, Leute. Der muss booten.
Jawoll! Lass mich rein! VT, lass mich rein! Die Musik!
Lass mal in die Matrix.
Bist du der Milchmann? Sieben Monate, Dankeschön!
VT, ich mach das schon, lass mich einfach ran.
Genau, das gab es im ersten Teil auch.
Du Leute mit NA-Aim. Perfekt.
Huge!
Zum Glück haben sie Titanfall nicht übersetzt. Das wäre es jetzt. Feindlicher heruntergefallener Titan oder irgendwie sowas.
Wo geht es hin? Oh, ein Titan. Der muss gewascht werden.
Ich schnaub voll rein gerade. Komm, wir catchen jetzt die Rakete. Schieß auf mich, Alter.
Huge Effizienz, Leute. Habt ihr es gesehen? So sieht die Effizienz pur aus.
Huge Effizienz. Stats sind alles KD. VT spielt auf KD, eindeutig.
Fünfer KD. Der kickt mich raus, wenn ich zu sehr sacke.
Wenn ich unter den Dreier KD falle, kickt der mich raus. Kacknoob, uninstall.
Machen wir Major Anderson. KD oder Win-Loss? Who cares Win-Loss? KD.
VT weiß, was sich gehört.
Okay, man sollte runterfallen.
Ist das ein Gegner oder zwei? Es ist ein Gegner.
Achtung, Huge Play.
Konnte man die nicht irgendwie kaputt machen? Man konnte doch die Gegner da rausreißen,
oder? Was machen wir jetzt?
Achtung, ich dachte, ich kann es elektro rauchen.
Was ist das? Man konnte Batterien aufheben.
Die Gegner sind Kacknoob.
Achtung, Huge Play.
Granate rein.
Schon alle tot.
Was haben wir denn hier? Wir haben Vortex, Schild, Elektro Rauch.
Das war das, was wir eben gesehen haben, dieses Schild.
Okay, wir probieren mal den neuen aus.
Granatwerfer.
Easy win, easy win.
Wir waren volle Leben.
Okay, das ist eigentlich ziemlich leicht.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich leicht.
Die gegnerischen Pilots sacken aber hart. Ich meine, ich bin der übelste Nuke-Pilot, gerade
in der Welt.
Insane.
Ich bin geboxt.
Ist der gerade vor mir gespawnt?
Ich glaube, der ist nicht gespawnt.
Chatvertrauen in 2020, das kann auch hinlosgehen.
Vertikales Gameplay.
Ich bin von Aliexpress.